yeah welcome to this video playing
castle Lea from the Netherlands I just
turn very recently played him don't
remember what exactly happens but is a
frequent opponent yeah this each floor
line is getting hugely popular amazingly
enough mm yeah this was just played in
the game in the World Cup counts key
with black against a numbered yar off
this d5 was at age five I think h5 is
what mamedyarov plate what a weird
opening but actually am i playing if he
takes on the form
and may be h6e m-maybe h6 who taking
that son surprising 'if I've and I can
play five on or d5 it's both are not
ridiculous I just take on c4 for that
matter okay but d5 looks good getting
rid of the night and allowing me to to
actually capture on h5 the question oh
yeah I was more expecting 95 ok
and yeah hope to continue now I'm its
sub pressure on the center I could take
here simply but then it takes on d4 I
can take h5 of course
I don't d 5 gives away a 5 but it's not
the way this isn't necessarily bad yeah
why not actually if it takes me 5 i'm a
95 95 bishop if i can just take age 5
and this should should be good actually
taking with the Queen even as possible
of you kept all the books both on both
ok probably the thing is I haven't
sacrificed anything for this position I
can just hopefully just take si form
yeah even now or is there something
better yeah yeah just take it yeah I'm
not even material down for that here and
it's probably a very good position ok
he's attacking on c3 but at the DD
successive that that makes me wonder d6
bishops III check King f1 a 95
Versailles the problem ok so let's play
simple move and kaveh c3s to threats d6
and why is he ever going to replace the
skin cannot play the night because if I
was hanging so
yes
hmm
mmhmm yeah speak to us hanging I don't
want to move it
okay this is the most dynamic way to do
to do thanks just cover it with the book
oh wait I can also play be one rupee one
and then is six Quincy too easy and I
can you know be one who can play Quincy
to and clean g6 probably so I better
better prevent dad I mean it's a huge
position anyway fee I mean if it just
drops back the Queen I can play moves
like 94 or something okay so need to do
that
okay he's got the check him
queen e 559
I know I could for a moment I thought
okay should I thought about about checks
but this is this is nonsense of course
okay going to f5 some a possible move
but then i have this check ok check
came
mm yeah of course you don't want to
don't want to exchange Queens but where
do I go it's still it's still a very
active position but I am down low in 30
seconds I only see that now positional
son stole very interesting but the time
ya need to just be kukuri
still probably check quite good for
white to put it mildly you know what is
winning Bishop g5 v place King King
takes
it's no mate we probably missed the time
check
check-check
SI mortgage 20 seconds is not much
even though and I found it easy position
like that check check check
check
check
at some point you will play h4
ok I won't manage just too slow game
drawn ah yeah I really first game of a
session is really tricky with the time
management it's always tricky with me
but this time it was so far too much
yeah guess this position is just just on
play ball almost for lucky let's uh
let's see check this looks shockingly is
terribly dangerous yes computer actually
gives it as completely equal but it's
very very tricky 97's probably right
here damn night here white is some is in
excellent shape on she winning 30
seconds yeah you can do that so that's
not impossible to hang yeah but I'm only
managed to draw due to the due to the
time this h4 line is an excellent of
good idea it seems at hard too yeah
people have not really figured out yet
what what to do against it it seems that
my personal recommendation would be
would be to play c6 here for black it's
not a very room fat like move it's more
like sloth move but the good thing is
you're not getting mated or something or
get a quick age 5 thrown at you because
it bolsters the center so that age 5 is
not so powerful in those technical lines
so it's not quite clear at the moment
how black should play at least what he
did here turn out to be a quite
dangerous maybe d5 for special as
possible this also or
a good problem alright thanks for
watching